das war kein grund das ist ja
interessant dass ganz deutschland über
den impfstoff redet nur die kanzlerin
ewig lang nicht sie hat ihre eigene
statement nicht dazu benutzt sich dazu
zu erklären und das hat dann sage und
schreibe 45 minuten gedauert
ist die damen und herren in der
bundespressekonferenz oder besser gesagt
der bundes merkel konferenz dann dazu
kamen das zu diskutieren was den leuten
tatsächlich auf den nägeln brennt
nämlich ist genug impfstoff da das
schulthema ist ausgiebig besprochen
worden für mich ein wichtiger wichtige
erkenntnis zweierlei erstens ich nehme
angela merkel schon ab ich habe heute
schon diese zerrissenheit denn ihr
gespürt dass sie merkt wir kommen zu
langsam voran das ist schon ein neuer
zungenschlag und auch neuer gestus und
sie hat sich heute erneut in ihrer
paradedisziplin präsentiert sie ist eine
perfekte problem erkläre rinn aber eben
keine lösungen sie ist eine perfekte
zustandsbeschreibungen mit also wirklich
gut gesetzten worten aber sie ist ja
eigentlich für die lösung zuständig und
es drängt sich immer mehr die frage auf
ob sie teil der lösung oder teil des
problems ist und so wie ich sie heute
erlebt habe ist die teil des problems
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren